I'm disappointed in where things are at
Ground Zero right now I think it's sad
on the other hand I do think the people
involved or trying reasonably hard into
the circumstances and but there's really
not a great deal of vision there it
begins it begins really right back the
morning of September the 12th when
Governor Pataki who had the most
authority in this situation made the
decision to keep everybody in place who
was a player in this situation the Port
Authority which owned the World Trade
Center developer Larry Silverstein who
at least the Twin Towers and most
importantly to keep the program in place
a program by program i mean the
functions of the buildings so you know
the World Trade Center was 10 million
square feet of office space plus some
retail and some other commercial space
that's what was transferred into the new
project with the addition of a memorial
and some cultural facilities and the the
prescription that it be in a different
physical format obviously not two
110-story towers again but spread out
around the site in a different way but
you know we never really looked into
completely different uses for the site
we never we never really fought from
point zero we might say about what the
ideal thing to do there would be instead
we took a program that goes back to the
original World Trade Center in the early
60s and it was never really that
effective or successful for most of its
life and decided to replicate it and
then came all the complex political
things that flowed from that so it's
taken in inordinately long time its cost
a huge amount of money and we still
don't really have anything that I think
the world
can kind of look at and say this is a
great achievement that shows us that the
United States has come back from this
thing in a noble way the office building
that's going up is sort of okay but it's
not I don't think going to be a
distinguished or boot particular
beautiful building it's not the doesn't
show all that we're capable of in terms
of architecture similarly the other
office buildings that have been planned
for the site most of which are on hold
now because of the economy are better
than the average you know piece of junk
on Third Avenue that's true but that's
not a very ringing endorsement and then
for you know this this site that is so
critical to the eyes of the world where
we had the opportunity to show the world
that we could do something that was bold
and visionary we have really not
succeeded at doing that I think a great
tower would have had a place there
either a pure tower just as a symbol
like sort of the Eiffel Tower of the
21st century we might say or remembering
that the United States has after all the
birthplace of the skyscraper a building
form that we've now given to the world
it was now common all around the world
what better place if we're looking to
show the world that in fact we have not
been defeated by this attack than to
come back to this place in this country
in this time and build the most advanced
skyscraper we could possibly imagine the
one that will bring the art of
skyscraper design forward yet again and
instead we're not doing that we're doing
a a building that is not that different
from a lot of commercial buildings built
everywhere and in fact not as good as
many of them it's going to be very tall
it'll have a little more flair to it
than the old twin towers did but you
know that's that's it's not what it
might have been
you